hi I'm Thomas and I'm going to be
telling you about algorithms with more
granular differential privacy guarantees
I'll start by giving some background and
motivation and the the high level
question is how do we interpret large
privacy parameters
uh and that's going to lead us to
defining per attribute privacy or
partial differential privacy
and then I'm going to tell you about
some algorithms that provide per
attribute privacy guarantees so I'm
going to look at the tasks of koi
marginals
histograms and learning hubspaces and
then we'll wrap up
now I hope many of you are familiar with
differential privacy but I'll give a
brief introduction the setting is as
follows we've collected the private data
of several people with
stuck that through some processing
algorithm and that's produced
statistical information which we're
going to release to the the whole world
now the concern is that that statistical
information that we made publicly
available is going to leak some
sensitive details about the people whose
data with uh collected and we want to
prevent that and the way we formalize
preventing that is differential privacy
so the way we we do that is we consider
the real world that I just described to
you in an ideal world where your data
has been completely removed from the
end now the ideal in Real Worlds are
going to give you different
distributions and outputs and the
guarantee of differential privacy is
simply that these output distributions
are similar so any event e the
probability of curls in the real world
is the most e to the Epsilon times the
probability it occurs in the ideal World
Plus Delta now I'm going to ignore Delta
because that should be very small
but the intuitive interpretation of this
is that if there's any bad outcome that
you're concerned about
the probability that this occurs in the
real world is the most eagerly Epsilon
times the probability occurs in the
ideal world
ideally of course the ideal world has
very low probability of that bad outcome
occurring
okay so how does this interpretation
work
now if Epsilon is 0.1 then that means
the probability of a bad event increases
by at most a 1.1 Factor
Epsilon equals one is a 2.7 Factor at
most Epsilon equals three as at most a
20-fold increase in the probability of a
bad outcome but if we set Epsilon larger
things rapidly start to fall apart so
Epsilon equals 10 means we're looking at
20 000 fault increase in the probability
of that outcome and once you reach
Epsilon equals 20 the probability of a
bad outcome could increase by a factor
of a billion
now this is I want to emphasize that
this is not a vacuous guarantee but it's
definitely getting quite hard to
interpret this
but despite this uh a minority of real
world applications of differential
privacy do consider large values of
Epsilon greater than 10.
so there's a disconnect here we we're
using large values of Epsilon but we
don't have a good way to interpret it
because we're facing this exponential
cliff
now there's an informal intuition that I
think a lot of people have which
basically says that if your algorithm is
it's nice if the data is natural and if
the adversary or attacker that you're
worried about is realistic
then the real privacy guarantee is bent
instead of this exponential Cliff it's
going to be a much more gradual failure
as if someone comes up
high level question
of course is can we formalize the
central
now I think it's important to be able to
formalize this and give explicit and
robust guarantees because it should be
falsifiable we don't want to be in a
situation where we just have a hand wavy
intuition this is logical ones are
always good
we should know what the criteria are for
when it's okay uh and when it definitely
is not okay
so what we look at in this work is
what are nice algorithms can we
formalize this can we construct
something so our contribution
specifically is that we're going to
design some some algorithms that satisfy
a more granular DP guarantee that we
present as a way of formalizing a
algorithm being nice
okay so what do these nice DP algorithms
look like and then the easiest way to
address this question is to flip it
around and ask what the worst case
differentially private algorithms look
like
and the canonical example is randomized
response on your most sensitive
attribute
so just imagine your most sensitive
binary attribute it could be whether you
have some disease or whether you're
pregnant whether you've committed some
kind of crime
and now imagine an algorithm that takes
that attribute and correctly outputs it
oops
with probability one over one plus e to
the minus Epsilon
and with probability one over one plus e
to the plus Epsilon these two add up to
one it will I will flip the bit and
output the Reversed value
now this satisfies Epsilon differential
privacy but if Epsilon becomes large so
the Epsilon equals 10 would mean that
you're revealing the sensitive bit with
99.995 accuracy
um so obviously this is not a good
algorithm and intuitively what's
unnatural about it is that it is
spending such a huge amount of privacy
budget Epsilon equals 10. on a single
binary attribute
and this
uh is not minus and we want to formalize
we want to formulate something that
rules this out and that's what leads us
to uh per attribute differential privacy
uh so we have various generalizations
with this definition but let's just
stick with uh per attribute differential
privacy so an algorithm is going to
satisfy Epsilon naught per attribute DP
if for all pairs of inputs x and x Prime
that differ only on a single attribute
of a single person
the output distributions are similar in
the the usual sense that the probability
of any event can increase by most of e
to the Epsilon multiplicative effect
now how this differs from the standard
definition of differential privacy is
that the standard definition allows me
to change a single person's data
arbitrarily now we're saying you can
only make a small change to post this
data
now this intuitively corresponds
to making an assumption about the
adversary we're basically saying the
adversary is only interested in a few
attributes so a single attribute or a
function of a couple of attributes
so this protects against the class of
attacks but it doesn't protect against
everything so for example it doesn't
protect against membership it doesn't
protect whether or not you're in the
data set because that's a function of
all of your attributes
uh that being said if you have Epsilon 0
proactive UDP and you have D attributes
then you have Epsilon DP under the
standard definition where Epsilon is
equal to Epsilon or times d
so you still get a standard DP guarantee
as a corollary of per attribute DP
now the claim I want to make
is that if I tell you my algorithm
satisfies per attribute DP with Epsilon
naught equals one and there are 10
attributes
this is more informative
than just telling you that we have a 10
DP guarantee
and hopefully there are scenarios where
you might be willing to accept this kind
of algorithm
when you are not comfortable with just a
10 DP guarantee so this is giving you
more information and in particular is
trying to encode something about how
nice yeah
okay so now is a good time to situate
this work relative to what's been done
before so in terms of definitions there
are plenty of papers that have given
definitions which are more or less
equivalent to our definition of per
attributp AKA partial DP
uh one thing that we did that is new is
that we looked at a concentrated DP
varying a partial DP which I think is
important because uh it gives you better
composition
but what I want to emphasize is our
contributions on the algorithmic side
so if you look at the prior work pretty
much all of that looks at some variant
of the LaPlace mechanism
where you just change the sensitivity to
to match your definition
or rather you change your definition to
match your sensitivity there's also some
work that looks at the the gaussian
mechanism but overall the the
algorithmic toolkit and the prior work
is quite Limited
so that's what we're trying to address
in this work and we're going to present
a couple of different algorithms so this
is a startup we're going to look at the
projection mechanism which gives you
average error guarantees for families of
queries
we're also going to look at a variant of
the multiplicative weights uh
exponential mechanism which uses like
more like a
Max error guarantee over the queries
we're also going to look at histograms
AKA Heavy Hitters and robust hospace
learning
uh and the overall message that I want
to emphasize about our algorithmic
results is that we show a separation so
we show that there are settings where
it's possible to have a small per
attribute guarantee but the
um
per person standard Epsilon is going to
be large
so this is a setting where uh
having this additional information a per
actual guarantee could be useful
okay let's uh start talking about our
algorithms let's talk about uh care way
modulus
um
so here our data is a vector of debits
for each person
and let's start with one-way module so
one-way marginals are just the mean of
all of the attributes
now understandadp this is a very easy
task or standard task we're going to add
LaPlace noise to each attribute mean
and the scale of total plus noise needs
to scale
with the number of uh attributes by
composition
uh under per attribute DP the scale of
them we also can handle the possums but
the scale doesn't grow with the number
of attributes now this is a trivial
algorithm we're just exploiting the fact
that we're doing per attribute DP and
Computing for attribute statistics
so where things get a bit more
interesting is if we look at k-way
conjunctions
so uh KOA conjunction basically I'm
going to pick all sets of size K sub
sets of attributes take conjunctions and
output the mean of those conjunctions
so now I have a much larger set of
queries and each query can depend on a
number of attributes there's no clear
way I can separate them out into per
attribute sets of queries
so a standard algorithm for this is the
projection mechanism
uh it's it's actually very simple you
add gaussian noise to each of the
queries and then you do a projection
step so you take the noisy answers and
you find you reconstruct some data set
why that is as close to whose answers
are as close to those noisy answers as
possible
and those projections have greatly uh
decreases the aircraft
and we can analyze this under per
attribute DP
now if you compare the standard DP
guarantee here
if you look we're looking at
concentrated DP but I want to ignore
that detail
if you know the average error of the
query so the number of queries is M
averaging over all the all the queries
this is a vector of query answers
the error grows as the minimum of two
terms so the first term is just the
guarantee I would get from noise
addition this grows with the the number
of queries M so this is not very good if
I have a large family of queries
but the second one the second term is
what I get from the projection mechanism
and here we see the error grows as the
square root of the dimension
mention of the Epsilon times n
under per attributes we get under per
attribute
privacy I can add less noise
uh and then the guarantee the error
grows not with D but with K so instead
of the total Dimension I only need to
look at the dimension of the queries
so there's a there's a separation here
however this is just for averager I have
to average a roll of queries
so it could be that 99 of my queries
have Great era but one percent have
terrible error so that's how we're
interested in also getting guarantees
for maximum amount
okay so let's keep looking at KOA
modules carry conjunctions and look at
the maximum error
so a standard algorithm for this is the
multiplicative weights exponential
mechanism which is based on the early a
private multiplicative way equipment
the algorithm is simply described as
polos so we maintain a distribution over
the the data domain
and the goal is to make that
distribution
match the private data set in the sense
that it gives answers that are close to
the the true answers
what we do is we use the exponential
mechanism to select one query
such that there's a big difference
between the answer on that distribution
we're maintaining and on the private
data set
once we've identified that query we're
going to re-weigh the distribution
using the multiplicative weights update
rule so the distributions answer matches
the true answer
and then we're going to repeat and the
the nice guarantee of multiplicative
weights is that this is going to rapidly
converge
and the way we modify this to give per
attribute
guarantees is that rather than
thinking one query at a time we're going
to pick multiple queries in parallel
uh and here is the algorithm and all
that story detail I don't want to go
through it one thing to note is that
there's a parameter L which is the
number of queries we uh sample in
parallel if L equals one we get exactly
the standard algorithm
and we're going to say alt will be
something like d over K to get a beta
guarantee
so the standard guarantee for
multiplicative weights is that the
maximum error over all the queries uh is
is this expression
if we look at the per attribute
guarantee
per attribute privacy guarantee we
basically get to substitute the D with a
K so again we're going to replace the
uh total Dimension with just the
dimension of the queries and that's a
big win because we're often interested
in queries with Dimension like two or
three
but there's still a log D term that
appears
uh there there's an important caveat on
this result so we don't actually get to
bound the maximum error we get to bound
the worst case era averaged over a set
of owl attributes joint queries
which is an open problem to to close
that Gap
okay great so I've told you about the
projection mechanism multiplicative
weights which are algorithms for
answering families of queries such as
kiwi marginals let's look at histograms
so I'll give you some background on
histograms
so the data is just a set of points in
some domain X we're going to take X to
be 0 1 to the D
so the attributes
now we're interested in the frequency of
a given element y so the frequency of Y
is the number of times y occurs in x13x
now the histogram is to Output the
histogram problem is the output F sub y
for every y up to some additive error
The Heavy Hitters is a closely related
problem and basically an equivalent
problem where it asks you to Output a
list of all y's that occur with a
certain frequency
foreign
these problems are basically equivalent
except that the Heavy Hitters is asking
for a succinct representation
uh now this problem is extremely well
studied under differential privacy most
of the time people consider variance of
the problem we have communication or
computation constraints which we're not
looking at
but
the canonical algorithm if you're not
worried about communication or
computation is just to add LaPlace or
gaussian noise
uh to each of the frequency
counts uh independently
now the scale of the noise
uh is
one of the Epsilon and it's important to
know this doesn't depend on the demand
size is because adding or removing one
person only changes the frequency of one
element
uh now the maximum error is then just
obtained by a union map so there's two
to the D elements we take a union bound
over 2 to the D LaPlace noise samples we
get error D of Epsilon
and there's an additional trick we can
throw into this
so we can truncate the noise if we have
Delta greater than zero approximate
differential privacy we can truncate the
noise at log one over Delta over Epsilon
and then we can get an error bound
that's independent of the dimension
D now I've just given you an algorithm
which is very good in a sense people
understand that histograms are easy
understand a differential privacy which
raises the question why would you want
to consider per attribute differential
privacy for an easy proper histograms
and the reason I think this is
interesting is that the histogram
algorithm I just described is it in a
sense a worst case outcome it's
precisely the kind of algorithm that we
don't we want to rule out with with
partial TP because it's not nice
and to illustrate why that is the case
let's suppose I'm the adversary I'm
trying to figure out whether or not your
data is included so there's an ambition
inference question
now assuming the histogram is Spar so
there's no collisions this is just the
question I'm asking is f sub y 1 or F
sub y zero where Y is 0 data
similarly I might want to know what your
secret bit is so I know that your data
is y naught or y1 I'm trying to figure
out which
this just works out to figuring out is
is the pair f y naught fy1 one zero or
zero one
and the problem is
if the Privacy parameter Epsilon is
greater than one then the scale of the
noise that I'm adding the the algorithm
is adding is less than one which means I
should be able to distinguish between
these
so we actually get this exponential
Cliff where
as Epsilon gets larger than three or ten
or whatever but probably that I can
figure out your secret information is
very high
and to make matters worse if I apply
this trick of truncating the noise
then this
roughly corresponds to say I'm going to
release your data in the clear with
probability Delta so histograms are
an easy problem but they're also a worst
case problem
okay so let me describe our algorithm
for Heavy Hitters which avoids The
Source case uh this worst case Behavior
by looking at perhaps
so the key idea
is to take the attributes
split them and then recursively compute
Heavy Hitters on the subset so if you
look at the diagram I have here
go to table each row is one person's
data I'm going to split it up based on
the columns
I'm going to compute the recursively
compute the The Heavy Hitters on the
left and the Heavy Hitters on the right
um
and now once I have those heavy headers
I can concatenate those Heavy Hitters
from the left to the right
and this is giving me a short list of
all the Heavy Hitters at the top
so
I only need to look at the frequency
F sub y for y that's on my short list
so when we're doing the analysis of this
algorithm this means you only need to do
the union bound over the short lists
rather than over the exponential set
of all possible strings
and those are the Privacy analysis each
attribute is only looked at on the path
from the roots of the
but from the root to the leaf
so we can do a rough privacy analysis so
we can split the Privacy budget Epsilon
naught to Epsilon naught over log D for
each level
if you look at the total size of the
short list over the entire tree this is
roughly polynomial in D so I'll think of
a union bound over polynomial and D
the plus noise draws or each a scale log
via the Epsilon node and that gives me a
maximum error of log squared D of reps
naught
it turns out we can actually shave that
one of those logs by doing some clever
accounting which I I won't go into
so we get Max zero log D over X form
so the separation here is that
understand a DP the max error
as D over Epsilon this is for Pure DP so
Delta uh and under per attribute DP it's
log D of Epsilon naught so there's an
exponential separation here for Pure DP
foreign
so let's uh give a give a summary and
wrap up
so again the motivation for this work is
finding ways to interpret logic Epsilon
by providing some additional information
by breaking it up into a more granular
gravity
um and we're trying to capture this
intuition that nice algorithms spread
their privacy budget of the attribute
that are spin up on a single attribute
this corresponds to making some
assumptions about the adversary
specifically they're only interested in
one or two attributes
um obviously there's limitations here it
doesn't protect against membership
inference attacks because that's a
function of all your attributes
and in general the interpretation of
this kind of guarantee is context
dependent
if you don't want to do conics dependent
things you're stuck with standard
differential privacy uh and our main
technical contribution is that we
provide several algorithms that give per
attribute differential privacy
guarantees for Gateway modules Heavy
Hitters half spaces
in all these cases we show there's a
separation between the standard per
person Epsilon and the product
our word demonstrates that there is
something algorithmically interesting
that can be done in the perattibute API
so lastly let's talk about some further
work
um obviously the high level question of
interpreting privacy guarantees is still
open uh a couple of thoughts on this I
think whatever justification we come up
for tolerating larger epsilons than we
can interpret normally should be
falsifiable it shouldn't just apply
everywhere there should be specific
conditions under which digestification
works
uh and
we should not be aiming to replace
differential privacy with a new
definition it should just be a way of
supplementing it with printing providing
additional information
uh obviously other direction for further
work designing and analyzing more
algorithms I think we
only surface in this work
um there's also natural extensions like
having different epsilons for different
attributes obviously not all attributes
are equally sensitive
uh and I think the a great question
would be to find applications where this
kind of formalism actually is providing
useful additional information
thank you very much for listening